hello everyone and welcome back to round
nine of the 2021 norway chess it's
magnus cross and versus sergey karyakin
the two old rivals who have battled that
out uh if you remember in 2016 in the
world chess championship but here in
norway chess they are already playing
the second game in the first round uh so
in the first half of the tournament uh
karjakin won a very nice game against
magnus in the classical time format it's
carlson's only lost so far in classical
in this tournament and now magnus has a
chance to bounce back this is the
classical game uh let's see what happens
as it's really really a crazy game all
right so magnus now with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have e5 by
karaki knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 and of course you already
won with white now you have black you go
for the berlin defense we have knight to
f6 and now d3 so uh saying that uh the
the queens will remain on the board uh
we have bishop to c5 and now bishop
captures on c6 we have d captures and
white just castles here uh and now
knight to d7 so it's a move that's uh
been played quite a lot c3 uh and now uh
there are a couple of well there are
quite a few games where castles was
played it's uh the only move basically
that's played here and uh there's a
known a5 move which uh wesley still
tried against anishigiri and geary won
that game but here uh in this game we
have h6 by karjakin and it is now
already as of move seven that we have a
completely new game which is uh you know
uh really remarkable as we do have the
berlin defense so magnus continues
developing knight b to d2 and now black
castle so we have knights to c4 going
after that e5 pawn as one usually does
and rook to e8 now adding another
defender here and b4 uh you always have
to play that we have bishop back to d6
and now bishop to e3 so nicely
continuing development we have knight to
f8
uh and now comes knight f to d2 uh now
from here you can uh maybe capture the
bishop get the other knight the c4
you've cleared your way for maybe f3 if
you can if you maybe push d4 so you want
to have extra support for this pawn or
if you want you can even play f4 it all
depends on what black plays so knight's
the g6 now guarding that f4 square and
now knight captures on d6 so grabbing
that bishop c captures undoubling the
pawns and now grabbing more space on the
queen side with a4
sergey says all right i now have my
chance to strike in the center so d5
we have knight to b3 and now b6 so
taking away these squares from the from
the white knight and also now if
possible maybe you will even think it or
your light square bishop so a5 are now
ready to open up the a file and rook to
b8
we have queen to c2 by magnus and now
developing the queen connecting the
rooks uh now if black captures here you
don't have to worry about an early queen
trade uh and bishop to e6 now black also
continues development we have rook f2b1
magnus shifting all of the attention of
the game to the queen side and how do
you uh well how do you play this uh well
uh karjakin uh replies in a very
principled manner he plays rook to e7
first and now asking magnus what do you
do magnus continues with c4 now asking
do you want to capture or do you want to
push d4 and then i will have three very
nice pawns here on the queen side
karakin pushes d4 now you could also
consider f5 right away but he first
pushes d4 chases away the bishop bishop
to d2 and only now f5 a very principled
decision uh as uh well as a general rule
when your opponent is coming at you on
the queen side you want a counter attack
in the center of the board or if it's
the king side you also want a counter
attack in the center of the board so
here we have eight captures on b6 uh
eight captures on b6 and now just f3
strengthening the center here and now
rook to f7 now you can move the queen
you can even double up on the f file
maybe capture here open up df file do
some
damage along those lines but also if
if you want you can also shift the
attention to the a file so this is what
karaoke will have to decide we have rook
to f1 magnus also switches now to the f
file
and king to h7 now
improving the position of the king a
little bit with e captures on f5 by
magnus bishop captures and now it's a
question of how do you continue this
because um
if you look at the placement of all of
the pieces on the board black is just
better the the queen here is very oddly
placed not really doing anything except
guarding that backwards d3 pawn the
knight doesn't really have any squares
the bishop here also what what is the
bishop doing so you might have some
ideas of maybe rook a6 doubling up on
the a file but as the game is
progressing it seems that karaoke is
shifting the attention to the king's
side so maybe going to the queen side
isn't that best of an idea so one thing
you could do is something like maybe
knight c1 to d2 to g3 and then maybe you
know you gain some squares here maybe
knight to e4 in the future but that's a
lot of moves and black also gets to play
uh so magnus says okay maybe this is a
bit too much let's go for bishop the e1
first now i get the control of the
second rank with my queen here and also
i can shift my bishop to g3 also i
prevented the queen from reaching the h4
square so yeah you know not not bad uh
karjakin shifts the queen over to the
king side queen to g5 now you have to uh
well be very careful here knight to f4
is coming then you're gonna have a lot
of pressure for example knight to h3
check will be possible queen to e3 check
going after the d3 pawn you also have to
keep an eye on this so rook to d1
defending the spawn not
you don't want to lose it and now h5
karaki now wants to play h4 h3 and uh
bust open uh the position so uh what do
you play here magnus now chases away the
black queen but now queen to h4 uh we
have rook d the e1
but now uh karjakin again has to decide
whether he wants to get put this rook on
on the queen side or shift it over to
the king's side he plays rook to a8 and
magnus immediately contrasts it with
rook to a1 and only now he shifts he
shifts it back with rook 8 to f8 now he
says all right your rook maybe isn't
that useful on the open a file all the
action will be on the king's side but
the magnus says all right let's let's
see it and he plays rook to a6 and now
uh you have to
first decide how how you want to go
about this so one way is to just defend
your pawn it's a kind of a boring move
let's say queen to d8 defends the pawn
and then the game continues and black
looks for a way on how to make progress
but uh karjakin says nope you are very
low on time i have a lot of time on the
clock let's complicate and good things
will happen and he pushes this pawn to
e4 and this is just beautiful
he's uh sacrificing this pawn so magnus
can capture this but you know a lot of
hidden treasures alert in the position
as you'll see so knight captures on d4
magnus accepts this pawn we have e
captures on f3 now what can uh what can
white to do here uh well you could
capture the bishop it seems like a very
nice idea however then comes f captures
on g2 and if you capture the queen it's
just g captures on f1 queen and it's
checkmate so this is one idea so you
can't go after the bishop just you know
to remove one of the attackers we have
knight captures on f3 attacking
karjakin's queen here but now bishop the
h3
karjakin offers his queen for a very
nice checkmate of course if magnus
accepts this then rook captures an
f1-ish checkmate so karjakin really
going all out in this one he's not
satisfied with just winning one
classical game against magnus he wants
to beat him again with the black pieces
but magnus finds the only good defensive
move and that is rook to f2 so now uh
the the rook is helping out with the
defense of the second rank but also it's
not going to be a target on f1 and once
the bishop moves the queen will also
help out with the defense here so here
we have rook captures on f3 and now what
do you play if you play rook captures on
f3 then rook captures and white resigns
there's no move you can play here uh
because if the rook is captured then you
play queen to d4 check and the queen and
bishop
really do not allow this king to move
you have to play king h1 now queen f2
and there's no defense against queen to
g2 checkmate so magnus has to capture
the rook but with the g pawn he plays g
captures on f3 and now
a very delicate situation and uh here i
think uh karaoke played a little bit too
fast because magnus was the one who was
very low on the clock and he didn't want
to allow magnus to you know uh think
during
sergey's time so he played
rook to f5 and we're going to discuss
this but knight to f4 seems to
get the job done much quicker you block
the bishops uh
uh well reach here the bishop no longer
guards g5 and now queen to g5 will be a
deadly threat if the king moves you can
even play something like bishop to g2
and it's uh well not much but for
example vegetable capture queen will
capture and then the game continues then
maybe you can consider bringing the rook
into the game this way but he played it
right away rook to f5 and this allows
the magnets to go for such a sneaky
sneaky maneuver uh that it's uh well
it's hard to believe that it's even
there so here he plays d4 and now he
says all right what is the rook actually
doing here uh because the g5 square is
not available to the rook the bishop
covers this square and if you go knight
to f4 now which kind of was the plan
then i play uh then you will not be able
to move the rook as the queen and king
occupy the same diagonal now this is a
pawn sacrifice but
a well worth it one
now uh it's hard to figure out what
karjakin wanted to with this rook to f5
move if his plan really was to play
something like knight
knight to f4 and then play rook to g5
check maybe uh then knight therefore on
the previous move would make much more
sense because then if bishop captures
through comes into the game with tempo
so who knows maybe he didn't want the
rook to be on f4 after capturing the
bishop maybe he wants the rook here to
be able to deliver this check right away
after the knight moves uh it's it's hard
to say either way magnus offered this
spawn so karjakin captures it it is the
best move
and now comes rook to a3 now this rook
is coming to help out with the defense
and it seems that white is surviving the
attack
uh and the problem for magnus is he's
down to two minutes on the clock whereas
karakin has some 26 minutes on the clock
and we still have to reach move 40 uh to
enable time control so here we have rook
to f7 uh now the
uh rook will no longer be a target here
and the king for the moment cannot move
because you will just lose this knight
so here we have rook to e3 uh getting
the other rook into the game and now
bishop to f5 that's how we uh get our
knight back into the game now we attack
white's queen queen to c3 offering a
queen trade and while you could do this
uh
can sacrifice the exchange for this so
maybe going uh into this end game where
magnus is up the exchange he has a rook
for a knight maybe not all that great so
he of course has to keep the queens on
the board we have queen to d8 and now
comes rook back to e1
and now uh of course the bishop here
is a bit awkwardly placed so rook to d7
putting more pressure on the bishop here
but queen to e3 now asking what do you
do and now karjakin is playing still for
the win he plays rook to d4 if he wanted
he could maybe play rook to e7 attack
the queen and then what do you play here
now you can't really capture the knight
covers that so you'd have to go back and
then you repeat rook to d7 and maybe ask
magnus what you play but it's it's like
uh he had to play faster because magnus
was the one who was low on time so he
played rook to d4 and now we have queen
to g5 now magnus offers a queen trade
and there's really no good way to
decline this because if you go and
defend the bishop then you lose the h5
pawn with check so he has to trade here
we have queen captures bishop captures
but at least now he picks up the pawn
rook captures on c4 but now karjakin
also dropped
with his time a little bit he's now down
to nine minutes but magnus is now below
one minute but okay time control has
been reached so you do get a little bit
of time uh every time you make a move
but still it's not a lot so here rook to
b2 magnus defense is pawn and now b5 b5
because you do not want uh
magnus to play b5 which uh probably
if b5 you're going to have to play c5
you're going to fix your pawns on dark
squares and magnus has a dark square
bishop maybe not the greatest of ideas
so of course karakian locks his pawns on
light squares king to f2 magnus has to
play fast he is incredibly low on time
and now comes c5
and this is the move that maybe comes a
bit too soon why would you do this
there's no reason to do this
the reason i think karaoke played this
is because magnus was the one who was
low on time and it's hard to find a good
move for black maybe just improving the
position but what is there to improve uh
i mean if you if you allow the engine to
crunch the numbers uh the engine gives
h4 sort of a sort of a way to prevent
white from playing h4 and cementing this
bishop here uh but it's such a weird
move okay the knight and the rook are
guarding the spawn
but it just looks weird but okay if you
have time of course you find such a move
but karakin doesn't or rather magnus
doesn't he's he wants to play on
carlson's time as well and he plays c5
but this allows magnus to really really
activate his rooks he plays b captures
on c5 rook captures and now rook to c1
the bishop is now guarding this diagonal
and now
the rooks are coming off the board of
course karjakin wants to prevent this
but now rook to d2 there's no way to
prevent this
one thing you could do is play rook to
e5 and then uh try and avoid it like
this but then we play h4 and then it's
black who's really
out of uh any useful moves if you play
something like uh bishop to e6 try and
get your bishop into the game we can
play rook to c7 then rook to d6 and then
we're really really putting pressure on
black's position we're putting this rook
to b7 to guard against the past pawn and
we just have a beautiful position so
instead karjakin decided to trade rook
so we have rook captures bishop captures
and now knight to e5 but now it's uh
merely a matter of technique but like i
said magnus extremely low on time he has
to play fast luckily he places a lot of
bullets so it's not a problem for him we
have rooked the c7 of course the rook
has to go behind the pass pawn that's
how we do it
b4 uh sort of trying to trick magnus if
he captures the pawn then knight to d3
check picks up the bishop but magnus not
very likely to fall for that rook to b7
is played and now we have bishop to e6
and it's uh well it's a very tricky
position he's trying to trick magnus uh
but what do you do here feel free to
pause the video and win the game for
magnus there's one very very tricky move
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook to e7 of course
we attack the bishop and the knight rook
to b5 also possible just attacking the
knight if the knight moves we pick up
the pawn with check this is a bit more
straightforward because you can
calculate it uh all the way to the end
so this is what magnus played
congratulations to everyone who was able
to find this idea uh because it's the
continuation that counts knight to d3
with check king to e3 and now bishop to
c4 sort of saving both of the pieces
and it's kind of a trick if you try rook
to a4 going after the bishop if the
bishop moves then we have a double
attack on this pawn but here black would
just sacrifice the bishop and well
there's nothing for you here now rook
captures b2 and there's no rook to be
for the knight covers that uh black is
getting uh queen here and uh well that's
just it so magnus did not fall for this
he played king to d4 attacked the bishop
with his king and he was in this
position on move 53 that sergey karyakin
resigned the game and the magnus wins
another game in classical time format
this being his fourth win in a row i
think and this what does this mean for
the standings well we're going to
discuss this but first
why did karjakin resign he has a
beautiful past pawn well the problem is
uh your bishop is attacked and the
bishop is guarding the knight so you
have to move the bishop somewhere that
makes sense to play something like
bishop to a6 maybe
still prevent the rook from coming to b7
but then we go after the bishop rook a7
and you only have these squares to keep
an eye on the knight so bishop to b5
we're going to play rook here attack it
and now you might um go bishop back to
a6 again we're just going to attack at
rook to b6 and that's it there's no more
there's nothing that can be done
all of the squares are taken uh from the
bishop and now you either lose the
bishop or the knight and that's it
there's no playing this so of course
they both know this and after king to d4
he resigned the game and like i said
another excellent victory for magnus
carlsen and you've already seen uh the
game
that rapper played earlier it was in my
previous video so you know what happened
with his result now we're going to check
out the standing so if you're still
waiting to check out
first game against tari maybe maybe you
know close your eyes but if not here are
the standings uh these are the standings
um so magnus is now in the lead uh he
overtook with 18 points to his 16 and a
half then we have furuja in third place
with 15. uh yanipon with 11. sergey
karyakin with eight and a half and
arientari with six with one round to go
uh we'll see what happens but i will
most likely
show the last the game of the day as
that one was also a beauty
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh rapper 2 really had a long run uh
it took magnus nine rounds to you know
get in front and get in front
at the first place we'll see if it holds
and tomorrow magnus is playing nipple so
it's going to be uh really awesome i
mean nepo does not have a chance to win
the tournament but at least he can ruin
the tournament for magnus and that uh as
he is his challenger you know for the
world championship title can be quite a
motivation so we'll see what happens
uh so that's the game once again hope
you guys enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank tom darrell isaac hits graph uh
francis air uh siri gautam yoshua and
chat is wonderful for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and for those
of you who keep asking me in the
comments i still do have my
white king usb
stick so there you have it
see you soon